If you have acute
coronary syndrome,
you have one or more
conditions caused
by a blockage of blood
flow to your heart muscle.
This is a medical
emergency, because you
may be having a heart attack,
a condition in which your heart
muscle begins to die.
Your heart is a
muscular organ that
pumps blood
containing the oxygen
and nutrients your body needs.
The main pumping chamber of your
heart is the left ventricle.
When your left
ventricle contracts,
it sends oxygen-rich
blood to your body
through a large artery
called the aorta.
Connected to your aorta
are small arteries
called coronary arteries.
Blood flows from your aorta,
through the coronary arteries,
to supply your heart muscle
with oxygen and nutrients.
If you have acute
coronary syndrome,
blood flow through
your coronary arteries
is severely reduced
or completely blocked.
One possible cause of reduced
blood flow is atherosclerosis.
In this condition, a
build-up of a fatty substance
called plaque can narrow
your coronary arteries.
If this plaque
ruptures, a blood clot
can form and block the artery.
A blood clot is the
most common cause
of coronary artery blockage.
Other, less common causes
of reduced blood flow
include coronary artery
spasm or dissection.
In a coronary artery
spasm, triggers
such as drugs, smoking, cold
weather, and extreme stress
or emotions can cause a
temporary and sudden tightening
of a coronary artery.
During a coronary
artery dissection,
the inside wall of one
of your coronary arteries
separates, which can
block blood flow.
Regardless of the
cause, a blockage
in either coronary
artery prevents
the oxygen and
nutrients in your blood
from reaching the part of your
heart supplied by the artery.
As a result, heart muscle
in that area starts to die.
Death of part of
your heart muscle
is called a heart attack.
It's also known as a
myocardial infarction or MI.
A blocked coronary
artery may also
cause you to feel sudden
pain, discomfort, tightening,
or a burning sensation in
your chest called angina.
This pain may extend to your
upper abdomen, shoulders, arms,
neck, and lower jaw.
If you have angina
when you're at rest,
or frequent angina
that prevents even
moderate physical activity,
you have unstable angina,
which is the main symptom
of acute coronary syndrome.
Other symptoms of
acute coronary syndrome
include shortness of
breath, dizziness, nausea,
and sweating.
If you've had a
heart attack or have
other types of acute
coronary syndrome,
your doctor may
prescribe oxygen therapy
to get more oxygen
into your blood.
You may take aspirin or other
prescription blood-thinner
drugs to prevent blood clots.
Thrombolytics also known
as clot-buster drugs,
may be used to break up
any existing blood clots.
Drugs such as
nitroglycerin and morphine
will relax your
coronary arteries
and relieve the pain of angina.
You may also receive drugs
called beta blockers that
slow down your heart and
reduce its need for oxygen.
Your doctor may also recommend
immediate surgical procedures,
such as coronary angioplasty, in
which a balloon-tipped catheter
inflates inside your blocked
coronary artery to open it.
may leave behind a mesh-like
device called a stent
After inflating, the balloon catheter
may leave behind
a mesh-like device called a stent
to hold your artery open.
Or you may have a coronary
artery bypass graft, or CABG.
CABG is a surgical
procedure in which the blocked
areas of the coronary arteries
are bypassed with veins or
artificial graft material.
Seek treatment
immediately if you
have the symptoms of
acute coronary syndrome.